I want to show you what it looks like
when millions of people are ordered to
evacuate at the same time this is
Interstate 4 in Florida it runs from
Tampa on the west coast all the way up
to Daytona Beach on the eastern coast of
the state it was packed with vehicles
full of people fleeing the storm
yesterday we spoke with one family
hitting the road last night just in time
yeah
Glenn josephic he decided late Tuesday
that it was time for him his wife Holly
and their two young children Jett and
Isaac to pack up
they're headed to stay with friends
further Inland the storm decides it's
going to shift West again right then
we're kind of in the in the worst path
the house right across from the
josephics is on the water so whenever
the storm's final path is he says his
family and the home could be in danger
so the storm goes there it still all
comes through Tampa yeah our biggest
concern was The Surge with two young
kids right and that's the main reason
why we're leaving just trying to
calculate the best time to leave
Gil Gonzalez and his neighbors have
already boarded up their homes with
plywood he takes care of his elderly
parents they've already fled the higher
ground we got sandbags and all kinds of
anti-flooding devices
Gonzalez and his family aren't alone
well we don't know how it how bad it's
gonna get some two and a half million
people are under evacuation orders up
and down the State of Florida hotels in
West Palm Beach on the Eastern side of
the state are already filling up with
residents hoping to escape Ian's
projected path as of right now they're
just mandatory evacuations we rode along
with sheriff's deputy Amanda Calderon
through Hillsborough County that's where
Tampa is she took us through parts of
the county where everyone has been
ordered to evacuate but you can't force
them to if they stay she has been
telling them that emergency response
service could be limited at what point
do you stop responding in a storm if it
becomes a danger to us they don't want
to risk us getting hurt out there
still some people are ignoring the order
and they're going to ride it out but not
the josephics it's the right thing to do
with the Mia kid we didn't have kids
maybe not
I gotta tell you on our way back to the
hotel last night we noticed most people
in this area have decided to stay look I
grew up in Louisiana we're used to
dealing with hurricanes all along the
Gulf Coast oftentimes you see people
stay after a hurricane but again the
mandatory evacuation orders are in place
up and down at least the western side of
the State of Florida guys we'll toss
back to you for now
all right thank you David I thought he
made a really good point that if you
decide to stay yeah you might not be
able to get help when you need it if you
need it if you need it Tony you're
familiar with staying during storm
warnings yeah I mean up in Florida the
calculator yeah grow up in Florida you
know people for years and years
particularly in a place like the West
Coast of Florida they've been hearing
warnings and then the storm wobbles away
and they don't get hit it's been 100
years since I've had something big so
people start to doubt they don't believe
it reports but this one seems to be
heading for you and I think you should
take those warnings seriously
um you know absolutely yeah and we'll
check back in with David a little later
on in the show